Yo
Hello everybody, I'm sorry.
I was gonna stream earlier.
I'm sorry.
I had work caught up to me and I had to do some work stuff.
Also, I ate my... I didn't tell you guys this before.
But, um, I didn't eat until...
Okay, I didn't even have... I didn't eat before my stream.
Before the April 1st stream.
And then, the Box stream, and then I didn't eat until 9.
Until 8pm.
So I had my first meal at 8pm.
And I got caught up with some stuff and now I'm here.
Playing my favorite game.
Where did I put my fish?
Is this my fish?
Oh, there's my fish.
Okay, give me a sec.
There we go.
Wait, I fucked it up.
Oh, give me a sec.
There we go.
Wait, where?
Where'd my fish go?
Oh, okay.
Oh, no.
What if I have to press that button?
Oh my- okay, it's okay.
The fish might randomly pop up.
It's the- it's the wild, wild west.
Look, there's my fish.
Om nom.
Om nom nom.
MHCup!
Thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
I ate nothing but my fish and my dinner.
Thank you guys!
Yes.
I still have a couple more hours left to go on my quota.
So, well not a couple.
I have nine more hours left to go.
Or eight.
I lost track.
It's either nine or eight.
So, if I do end, I'm using- I'm gonna be on my alt account.
As you can see, I'm on Don King Kong.
I am on Don King Kong today.
Because I don't feel like testing the main.
I don't- I don't know.
I don't know how the games are gonna be like on the main today.
So, I decided to be on Don King Kong.
I also don't think I'm like- I- I don't know.
Right now, my mind is not ready to like be a gamer.
I'm just here.
I'm just a cat.
I'm Doe Kitty.
I just- I'm just running away from my taxes right now.
That's why I'm here.
I'm not here- I'm not here to try too hard.
I'm here to- to- to- what is it called?
To people watch today.
It's not that late yet.
You know, usually the best time to watch the people watch is usually at like 3- when it starts being like 3 in the morning.
3 to 4 in the morning is when it's best to see like how degenerate the rank queues get.
So like, there's still some normal people out there.
There's still some normal people playing rank at the moment.
That's okay.
Alright, we're gonna warm up with some quick play- woah, okay, that was fast.
I was not expecting that.
Doe Kitty doesn't wanna do taxes right now.
Doe Kitty just wants to be a cat.
That plays Marvel Rivals.
And play DPS before she gets locked up in support jail.
Willingly locked up, by the way.
I put myself in that jail.
I- I put myself in that jail and threw away the key.
Don't let me out.
Don't- Doe Kitty is rea- Doe Kitty is not ready to commit tax evasion.
I am absolutely not ready for that.
That's exactly why I'm so fucking stressed out about my taxes.
Oh, I have yet to write my physical letter to my stupid tax center.
Alright.
The one time I get to play DPS.
Oh my god, I have to- Guys, I told you, I'm not writing it today.
I went through so much today, guys.
I am not mentally ready to fucking write a letter.
Also, for those who are wondering if I'm stacking with anybody.
No, I'm still loading right now.
I'm gonna see if I can kidnap anybody.
Like a random- not random person.
Maybe like, I don't know.
Let me see if I can- maybe someone will wanna let me kidnap them.
Just like how we kidnapped Choppa.
Wait, I'm throwing?
It's quick play.
It's- it's quick play, guys.
Nobody is- nobody's throwing because technically we're all throwing if you think about it.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're downstairs?
Oh my god, someone that doesn't wanna play high ground?
That's crazy.
Not playing high ground.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
This is- oh.
Goodbye.
I mean, I got the support.
So are they gonna do the rest of their jobs?
Yippee!
No one wants to be on point?
That's okay.
I'm like, okay.
Are they just gonna- okay.
You're really just gonna chill there?
That's fine.
Okay.
You're just gonna chill there.
Oh, Luna.
What you doing?
That's- oh, okay, nevermind.
Your Starlord's coming.
I was gonna say, that's sad, Luna.
Your Captain America fucking left you.
Oh, shit.
Do I have healers?
Oh, I do.
It's just quick play.
Alright, nice.
Wow, it feels so good to be- to actually be, like, decent at DPS when my enemy is just Bronze players.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, so this is what it's like to feel like you're actually a good DPS player.
Okay.
Oh, that is- where the fuck did his supports go?
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Oh, wait.
JK.
Not you.
Wait, where- where is he?
Oh, there you are.
I will solo ult you if I have to.
Oh, I don't.
Isn't that great?
I didn't have to.
Oh, oh, okay, there you go.
Yay!
Alright.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, look at that.
See, it's fine.
Are you gonna ult?
No?
Okay.
I know you have ult.
There's no way you don't.
We're almost at 90.
You passively gain ult at that time.
Hello.
You know, it could be worse.
I could be playing Hella in quick play.
What the fuck?
Bro, it's what- Bro, the round's not over yet.
You keep your ult for next round, buddy.
Oh.
See, this is why Psylocke counters Jeff.
Stop bullying the bronze, please.
Clea!
Clea and Spooky, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
I hope you have a good stream, Clea.
Hello, hello, everybody!
For those who don't know, my name is DokiBird...
and I usually stream on YouTube!
And Clea used to be my mama!
Yeah!
She drew- she did my...
this skin suit.
That was her!
But hello, everybody!
Alright, I could go Hella.
You know what?
I wanted to have an even worse time playing.
And before I miss every shot, but like...
it's the thought that counts.
I need to check my- oh my god, wait.
I need to check the battery on my mouse after this.
I need to- I need to check the battery on my mouse after this.
It'd be awkward.
It'd be awkward if my- if like my- if my mouse dies in the middle of a raid game.
My mouse dies in these games, I don't care.
I don't like playing on Khorne.
Khorne is so fucking- I don't know.
It's just- it's so...
It's in the way.
Where'd they go?
Oh no, not Captain America.
Okay, I am missing shots though.
Oh, I think I want to- maybe I should- oh-ho-ho... guys, I might need gamer subs.
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA Alright, let's not go silent like that.
Ah, haha!
Give me a sec.
I'm not hitting shit right now.
Today is maybe not a hella day.
Thank God I'm not DPS-ing right now.
Wait, what the fuck?
Are lowkey ulted?
Are you okay?
Wait, oh my gosh, where did he go?
I will kill you.
It does not matter to me.
Oh What oh no, it's okay.
I'm okay.
Oh, I'm not okay.
Oh My god, he's just beating my ass.
It's okay beat up the squirrel girls ass It's fine
Fucking Just walk.
He didn't want to die to me.
So he just walked off Is he okay?
Oh my god, if he he maybe he needs to be
Yes, guys, please Thor take the point Guys, what are you for?
I didn't know what it they're afraid of one scarlet, which that's dead
That's crazy Okay, little guy
Okay, give me right here and then I'll I'll antagonize this guy Man you can't keep that shield up forever.
That's it.
Yeah, I Know your arm gets tired It's scarlet which hello You think they know I'm right here This
Don't watch guys don't watch Like oh my don't miss that I didn't miss that.
Okay Okay, fuck me.
I guess we're gonna do swing your fucking shield.
I Don't know where that okay, that's fine Bro get your health back the health packs right there Turn around Turn around.
Oh My god, goodbye, goodbye little shark, let's swim away Away little guy go go go swim away
Oh No, I got RNG'd with my ult That's unlucky I could have actually killed I Could have actually got killed.
Oh fuck.
I almost died to that That's unlucky.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
What the fuck get away from me Yeah, there you go.
Why are you still here?
Still trying to kill me Okay, I believe in my star Lord, oh my god, I got him.
Holy shit.
I did not expect to win that fight.
Oh I shouldn't kill Come on I will farm.
I will farm the shit out of you penny.
Please this quick plays all I have right now Before I hate myself in ring.
I'll get my ult off you please There you go.
Get over here Mantis.
I know you don't have shit right now.
Oh Jeff hello Jeff.
I counter you get over here Come on, little guy.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, I Don't remember how to shoot the ground easy Hello, are you lost little guy?
Yay, oh Hello penny, oh my god, I need to kill this Mantis first.
Oh No I'll wait for the penny to finish whatever he's doing Before I go in and kill him and then goodbye
All right, now that I felt good about myself in quick play it's time for me to feel terrible in rank It's the circle of life Spooky thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Hey time to hate myself.
I've got time to face reality Goodbye bronze lobby I'll always remember you the time you let me just do whatever the fuck I would on Psylocke because you don't know how to Look behind you.
That's absolutely crazy That they don't even know how to just you know, they get hit in the back and they just don't turn around It's just very interesting.
I don't understand how they can't just look behind them Like do they just don't see me?
All right, I need to get water I just ran out of water so I'll be right back guys let's go and get water.
Oh Yeah, I've been trying those nasal strips I've been trying nasal strips the last The last Three day two days two days and it's actually crazy how How much more I'm breathing?
With my nose, I didn't realize like how little air has gone through my nose.
I don't know if it's working though I actually don't know.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm breathing more like that's a plus, right?
But actually, I don't know.
I don't know if it's working.
I Wake up and my mouth is closed when I wake up home.
Whoa, okay
So I have no idea But like it feels great cuz like it makes me realize like I'm like how tiny are my nose holes They have squished up are they cuz when I use the nasal strips my nose hose go away
It actually expands itself outside
But like, like, more airy.
Expand-o-hole.
Also like, now since I'm on alt account, I like have, I feel more comfortable playing other characters instead of, uh, do not say that!
But, um, um, but now I feel more comfortable playing, like I don't feel like, well, I might be throwing, but like I don't feel like I'm not throwing my own elope because it's not my main.
I'm still trying!
But I don't feel as bad if we lose.
Guilt-free, yeah.
I'm not a terrorizer!
It might not be my best character, but like, I'm trying!
You know, like, I always learn other supports in, in eternity lobbies, which is a bad, which is a bad idea, but I always do that.
I always like, whenever like a new character is met up...
What?
Shit, if the shoe fits, wear it.
That's like, you okay, buddy?
It sounds like he just got off, like, um, a nine to, like, a night shift, like, chain smoking.
Like, he's, he has, he's been chain smoking the last, like, five days and he just got off his night, like, his, his night shift right now.
Bros, the darkness.
Okay, I've seen people do, I've seen other...
Okay, it's like up here, and they do that, and then they do this, and then, um, right?
Or like, they do one here.
Oh, fuck.
I hate me.
Okay, okay.
I'm trying to figure out, I've seen, like, other Loki players play like this, but I don't know if this is right.
I don't know.
I think it is.
Oh, I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm trying my best.
Oh, shit.
That's not, that's a box.
God, I'm not used to being this high.
I'm so tall.
Oh, my God, I'm so, I'm so tall, guys.
I'm not used to it, guys.
Look how tall I am.
I can almost touch the sky.
I, I...
No, it is!
I see Loki players chill down there!
I swear to God, I'm just not gonna, I'm just won't be, like, doing any damage, and that's okay.
I'll be, like, here, maybe?
See the...
They don't know this is, they don't know.
Don't worry.
They'll think I'm just a clone.
Oh, shit.
Got deleted.
Oh, my God.
Oh, goodbye.
It's okay.
See?
Everything is fine.
Oh, my God.
I have to go down.
No!
Why copy?!
How did she, she died the moment I was about to copy her!
I even dropped down for it!
I dropped down for you!
I...
Can we portal?
No.
No, we cannot.
That's actually so unlucky.
I was just about...
I was just about to...
Oh, my God.
That's so unlucky.
Just about to do that copy too.
I'm not fucking peeking that shit.
There's, like, four people doing that.
You're so brave.
Someone should give you a medal for fucking looking into that.
Oh!
Okay, did my Luna die again?
Okay!
Goddamn!
Every time!
Please, I need a re...
Every time I want...
Please.
Please!
Oh, my God!
Hawkeye, you took it!
Bro, I was fucking shooting the Hawkeye!
It's Froggen.
God, chill.
I was shooting the Hawkeye!
The Hawkeye literally took...
The Hawkeye literally took it!
Okay.
There we go.
You see, this is why...
Guys, I'm just gonna say first game.
First game, guys.
First game here of the day.
First game at 11.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God, I'm alive.
I'm fucking alive.
Okay, I don't know about that, but that's alright.
That's okay.
What the fuck are you...
Why?
Why did you come back to me?
Oh, my God!
Bro, look at your team!
Okay, I don't know about...
I don't know what we should have.
See, this is why I need to play low-key.
I need to get better at this fucking character.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Alright, if anything bad happens to him, I can...
Guys, he killed two!
You heard that?
How is my other clone still okay down there?
Okay, that's fine.
Wait, I missed it, too.
That's crazy.
That worked?
Not gonna lie, I did not expect that to work.
Oh, shit!
Don't!
No, I do aim the ground.
I do aim the ground, but our Hawkeye was also stood...
Our Hawkeye also stood in front of the shots I was supposed to hit her mag.
So that was unfortunate.
I don't know if I can touch this.
I mean, I could try.
I'm slowly walking forward.
Okay, there...
Oh my god.
I had to touch it!
Okay, our Luna just has to live.
And then I can...
Okay.
Nevermind.
Goodbye.
I guess I...
Go this way.
Brother, it wouldn't let me change.
Okay, that's cool.
Oh, no.
Oh, goodbye, Neymor.
Goodbye.
It's okay, I'm learning, Loki.
No,
I absolutely try to aim the ground.
I know I can't aim fucking...
Loki's projectile is so weird sometimes.
So it's like...
Oh, please.
I'm aiming the ground.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh!
Live!
Live, please!
Okay, nice.
Nice, they all live.
Alright.
Everybody lives.
I had to do that preemptively.
I did not trust...
I did not...
Oh!
What the fuck?
It's fine.
Okay, well...
Can you kill me, please?
Can they kill me?
How is he the only one that ulted in that entire fight?
How do we have five ults?
Holy shit, okay.
Alright.
From downtown.
Hello, Celestial Lobby.
Celestial Lobby is so interesting.
Even though I'm not Celestial.
On this account.
To be fair, I'm like low Eternity.
So like, it makes sense.
Get on my...
Oh, that's fine.
Don't worry, I'm shooting the ground.
Don't worry, I'm doing it.
Oh shit!
You lost?
You lost the fight?
That's awkward.
I hope they kill him.
Thank God.
I was not expecting him to lose that fight.
I'm set up above.
Okay.
I'll be back here, guys.
They don't know.
How would they know?
You cancel her ult.
Oh my god, I have to reload.
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
We're all alive.
30 invents too!
No!
I'm coming back.
My copy!
Who did I copy?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god!
This is the only thing I can do.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Thank god!
Okay.
Please!
There we go.
Okay.
I'm trying to figure this out as much as I can.
And then...
Here I go!
Oh my god!
It's okay!
I'm like fighting for my life.
I'm like doing ring around the rosie right now.
It's alright.
There's no way my team can fuck that up now.
There's no way.
The Looney Tunes.
Wait.
Yeah, I was like there's no way they can fuck this up.
I traveled around the world.
Oh my god.
I just like ran around the fucking point.
Oh, first game of the day.
I'm not okay.
I'm definitely not warmed up.
Who would've thought?
Playing Psylocke does not translate well to Loki projectile.
It feels so different.
Chorus, thank you for the tier 1 sub!
Thank you!
Lord, thank you for the tier 1 sub!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
Nekka, thank you for the raid!
I really appreciate it!
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm like...
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I'm like learning Loki in Eternity lobbies.
The worst...
You know, to learn...
Hey!
At least I'm not doing it in one of the lobbies.
I'm doing it in Eternity lobbies.
MrBrokenBond, thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Brandon, thank you for the gifted sub!
Thank you!
Alright.
I heard that.
I know that Loki is one of the best supports right now.
Loki and Adam are one of the best supports.
And I need to learn it anyway.
Because I can't...
Guys, guys.
You guys know there's like...
Squids right behind us.
But that's okay.
We don't...
I know you guys do not care at all.
That's crazy.
They all just like walked past them.
It's so funny.
Sorry.
It's fine.
I forced him down.
I was like, fight down in the low ground with us.
I'm not letting you get high ground.
I may or may not have griefed our name.
Where am I doing that?
Look, I need the heal charge, guys.
I need the heal charge more than him on high ground.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Get down here and fight with us.
In the low ground.
You think you're better than us just because you're on the high ground?
Hit me.
Where?
Who said that?
Oh shit.
Okay.
Wait.
Kill him.
Nice.
Okay.
I was like, who the fuck?
Do you think he's gonna... okay, nice.
There you go.
I just...
They'll be fine, right?
Yeah, they'll be fine.
They'll be so healthy.
I believe.
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
I was like, they got that?
They lost their max one.
It's okay.
Don't worry, I'm a hero.
I'm a hero, guys.
Don't worry.
That one Wolverine will not hurt you now.
God, guys, don't.
Don't.
I'm healing the tanks, okay?
I'm trying to heal the tanks, okay, guys?
I'm...
I'm not missing the Hawkeye.
Guys, I think my depth perception is a little wonky right now.
It's cause I...
Guys, I think it's cause maybe I'm just tired.
Maybe I'm just tired.
That's why my depth perception isn't working so well right now.
Alright, did they push up?
I don't know.
Wait, they're not pushing up?
I'm surprised.
I thought they would push up.
Wait.
Alright.
Keep going.
Let's go.
Woo!
I copied that a while ago.
Let's go.
Look, I didn't think we would win that.
I didn't.
I definitely did not believe.
I am...
I definitely did not believe in my team.
By the way.
Can you guys tell?
Can you guys tell that I have a huge lack of trust on them?
Are they okay?
I can't tell.
They're fine, right?
Okay.
That's fine.
Just frontline as much as you can.
Alright.
Don't worry!
I have this!
Stand in it!
Oh, that's fucking right!
The invuln!
Okay.
They won't know I'm right here.
I...
I can't... I don't know where they are.
I don't know where they are.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry!
Yippee!
Thank you!
Yeah!
We got them to Eternity!
My eyes were so tired.
My eyes!
Oh my god.
We did it!
So easy, guys.
See?
Learning a new... Learning a character in Eternity is not that bad, guys.
It's...
It's not griefing if you win.
That's my number one rule.
It's not griefing if I win, guys.
I don't know.
I... I think I wanna... I'm gonna avoid their Moonlight.
Their Moonlight was... was definitely a person.
Uh...
Best...
Bro, I...
I don't think that's the right word there.
Best... Oh, man.
I have no idea what the fuck I was doing on Loki.
I have people that are like, oh...
Loki's pretty decent.
And I was like, do you have eyes?
I...
Here's my secret.
I don't know what I'm doing on Loki 99% of the time.
As literally as something runs at me, I just put like two clones in front of me.
And I'm like, can't kill me if there's three of me.
That's like, my game plan.
Someone runs at me, I'm just like, who... which one is the real me?
Yeah, which one is me?
I know, like, what my biggest flaw, though, playing Loki is that I don't know how to use my snaps correctly.
And, uh, I don't know, uh...
I don't know how to, like, use my snaps correctly in a more productive way.
And also, my clone placements are really bad.
I do watch, I do watch other, like, pro support players, though, to, like, learn.
How I learn is just I watch other players sometimes.
Which is how I learn how to play Apex and Overwatch.
I just watch how other players do it, and then I just, like, absorb them.
I'm like...
Oh, let's ban...
Oh, I was gonna ban Gru.
I'm banning Adam, okay.
I was gonna ban Hela.
Oh, it's just not fun to play against.
Hmm.
Yeah, so, like, I'm really bad with...
I'm really bad with...
Like...
I don't...
I wanna say I'm bad at clone management because I don't manage my...
I don't, like, look at my clone cooldown.
I just be like, one clone is down, I put all clones down now.
And then when we move forward, I was like, no clones here, all clones here.
And then when they destroy my clones, I have zero clone placement.
I'm just like, well, okay, fuck me, I guess.
I...
No clones, I guess.
We all die now.
Oh, William, thank you for tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Name her Bucky Ven...
Oh, we didn't ban Hela?
Okay.
I mean, why would we ban Venom when we have a Spider-Man player?
Like...
That doesn't make sense.
How the fuck would we get rid of him?
Let's practice more Loki, or Lokiburn.
Sorry, Lokitty.
Lokitty.
We have a Spider-Man player.
Why the fuck do we, like, nerf him?
Why the fuck do we break his kneecaps?
Like, he's already a Spider-Man player.
He's already nerfed as hell.
Almost went gamer there.
Uh, BB, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I said almost!
Alright, that's not a good big dog.
They have a Hela.
Man, if only we ban Hela.
Hela's half HP.
Do we even have a Hela player?
I'm scared.
It's okay.
We have a Moon Knight?
I swear, I never see Moon Knight in higher elo anymore.
Hela's 1 HP top right?
It's, like, so interesting to see Hela players here.
Oh no.
No, Groot!
Get in here!
Please, I sacrificed my clothes for that!
Oh, how's your...
We just let her survive out there?
Let's beat up that bird.
Yeah, beat up the fuck...
Wait, why would the Spider-Man player not ban Hela?
We literally said fuck our Spider-Man one trick.
Let's not give him anything in this world.
We let them have Hela and get rid of fucking Venom.
We do not like this guy, apparently.
He wants a challenge.
Yeah, it definitely is a challenge.
Okay, if they... I hear the Hela to my left.
Oh my god.
I hope they kill my...
Oh wait, okay.
He's dead.
Okay.
I was gonna say, I would be okay if they kill my Sue.
Because then I get to live.
Oh, that's not where I want to put the clone.
Alright.
See, I don't have my clones.
I don't clone management.
I literally just place clones until I have no more clones.
Break wall, break wall.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I just walked around until she stopped shooting me.
Oh no.
That's fine.
We have... oh okay.
It's not fine.
Oh wait, they used Mantis ult.
That's good.
Oh shit.
Oh, that's fucked up.
Lil, does he know?
I am not Loki.
Guys, Hela's just sitting here.
Menacing these.
Bro!
I'm just letting him... I'm just letting him sit there.
Please someone shoot him.
I'm walking forward.
Oh, and he still tries to kill me.
What is wrong with you?
Why did we just let him do that?
That's fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
We just let him literally just stay in the back for 20 years.
That's actually crazy.
Okay, just...
Hey guys.
We're like a little family.
That no-rag, that fucking...
Okay, our strange is a little too excited.
Okay.
I wish I...
Yeah, I can put another clone up here.
Don't worry.
It should hit you, right?
I'm contesting top, right?
Don't worry, I got you Groot.
You're so healthy.
My low-key clone is just shooting you.
Oh shit, don't worry, I got you.
Oh.
Who got them?
It's okay.
Groot, please.
Oh my god!
I haven't seen that combo in so long.
Where is the Hella?
Where did the Hella go?
Did we kill her?
I don't know.
I'm so confused and scared.
She could be anywhere.
She could be here right now.
They actually did the combo.
It's crazy.
They're running...
Oh, they're still running triple support.
I don't know if it's working though.
For them.
Okay, maybe it is.
Okay, don't worry Groot, I got you.
Don't worry Groot!
Alright, someone break this so I can...
Oh fuck, am I the only one pushing cart?
I am.
Wait, hey, it's working!
I'm just more of a support.
Oh, I thought I heard somebody.
I'm getting a little paranoid.
He has to do it now.
Yeah, I was gonna say, there's no way he's gonna...
He has to do that now.
Alright, don't worry.
We're still healthy.
Wait a minute, there's three of us.
We're still so healthy.
Oh!
We're still...
We're not healthy anymore.
It's okay!
I didn't use anything because they used everything.
Guys, that was the strat.
I didn't use anything so they used everything.
It's not because I got overwhelmed.
See, look at that.
That's called restraint, guys.
You gotta be able to restrain yourself.
It's always hella.
It's always hella up top.
It's fine.
I believe in us.
Look.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh,
nice.
Nice.
Look at that.
Look at that fucking prediction right there, guys.
Holy shit.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Look at that prediction I had there.
That was a crazy good prediction, though.
You gotta admit.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, I have to reload.
I have to reload.
Please.
Please, I have to reload.
Please live.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I keep having to reload.
Okay, nice.
We're gaming.
I was not panicking.
No, no, no, no.
I had to reload.
I was just stuck on like a 30 second reload, chat.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yeah, the pain of every support.
The reload.
Guys, I needed that.
Exactly.
Of course.
It's just like Apex.
You have to reload after like one shot.
Banana, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
You guys should free wins.
They probably...
Wait, who was the...
Who was the cleric and dagger?
Yeah, I'll farm them.
That's sad.
Being farmed on one...
No, my worst...
I'm praying that Jeff never becomes meta because I don't...
I feel like Jeff is just too much pressure.
Because you're supposed to be a...
Playing Jeff is like playing King Jeff and like...
That's way too much pressure for me.
I won't be in the backlines, thank you.
Just trying to be in the backlines.
I hope Jeff never becomes meta.
Just be like a specific niche pick.
What if I just break this for him?
I almost...
Oh, they have man...
Oh, they're running widow.
They have widow, man.
I was about to just break it.
Apparently what I learned was that if you're playing...
If you have a Groot...
If you're playing...
If you're playing Groot, you have to play Loki.
Because Loki is just so strong.
It's just so strong for Groot, he is.
I got really scared.
Oh no, I have to reload when I was setting up my cannon.
Oh, that's the worst part.
Please, where are you?
Oh my god, you're alive!
Cloak is half HP.
Cloak no fade.
Nice.
I did it.
Oh shit.
It's fine.
Our guy is almost close to his ult anyway.
I hope that Cloak does.
Oh no.
Wait, this is so easy.
Wait, when did Rengar...
Who are you trying to hit?
Widow?
Widow is dead already.
Who are you?
No, he is not.
It's okay.
The Widow didn't know where I was.
I mean, they have to change team ups.
If they don't, the game is going to be so fucking boring.
I'm already bored with the current team ups.
I want more experimentation.
Because then it's just going to be the same thing over and over again.
Which is basically how Apex sort of died.
Okay.
I'm a hero.
Don't mind Invisible.
What she did was...
She didn't do jack shit.
I'm a hero.
I saved myself.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
I lived.
What a hero.
I know.
Don't worry.
Do you think he...
Do you think I saved him?
Oh my god.
I'm actually...
Bro, there's no way the Spider-Man...
There's no way.
Oh my god.
The way the Spider-Man lives.
Holy shit.
I was not expecting our Spider-Man to live there.
That actually felt like...
An impossible feat.
I have ult again, Guru.
Oh, Jesus.
Oh!
What?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm still a hero.
I'm alive.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
We did it.
I saved myself.
I am my own hero.
Why did he get you?
I don't know.
He just...
Maybe he just hates...
He just hates Sue.
Why?
Why do you keep...
Oh, he missed?
How did he...
I mean...
Yeah.
I had the same thought, too.
I was like, how did he...
How did he miss?
Get in here.
Oh, it's fine.
It should be fine, right?
I believe.
It should be fine.
Yeah.
We're fine.
See?
Are you on lowkey right now?
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm a good lowkey player.
I didn't...
You did.
I'm good at saving myself.
But the Pope is a pixel person, right?
I don't know about my other supports, though.
There goes my hero.
I'm winning!
You're right.
I am winning, chat.
All in a day's work.
Nice!
Alright, who is the...
Who the fuck is the cloak that...
Is it pixels?
I'm gonna check.
I'm gonna check if it is pixels.
What is this?
Hey there, DonKingKong.
It's been four days.
Wait, has it been four days since I...
What?
There's no way...
No, okay.
I thought...
I was like, there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
History.
Alright.
I know they ran triple support.
Is it O-I-I-D?
Or this one?
Which one was it?
Who was the guy?
He played a lot of characters.
I don't know which one is it.
I'll just avoid...
Which one is it?
They both played cloak.
I don't know which one was the worst cloak player.
I'll just avoid...
I could just avoid both just in case.
No, they just said...
They literally just said...
They were like...
That cloak and dagger threw my game.
Yeah, so I was like, which one?
Which one?
Oh, you're right.
No, I'll just avoid both.
They were both pretty bad, not gonna lie.
I mean, this guy has 9k damage on strange.
Or they just swapped strange players?
They could've.
Yay!
O-I-I-D was the worst one?
Oh, okay.
I don't want to waste my voice slots then.
Okay.
You're unbanished.
Welcome back to society.
You've been unbanished from the lands.
Alright, I'll be right back.
I'm gonna get tissues real quick.
I need to blow my nose.
I'll be right back.
I ran out of tissues.
Alright, I'm back.
I am...
7TB broken?
I don't think I've ever had 7TB.
I think when I left Twitch, the first time I left Twitch, 7TB was not a thing yet.
Or unless they fixed it?
I don't know.
Did I add it?
I don't remember.
I don't use it enough.
I don't have it, right?
Oh, I don't have it, yeah.
No, I just don't have it because I'm too lazy to set it up myself.
Unless a mod wants to set it up for me.
I have too much other stuff to do.
Alright, let me check my mouse.
Okay, 39%.
That should be enough for today's stream.
39% should be enough.
I should avoid...
I was like thinking about drinking...
Caffeine?
But then I remember.
I have a 12.30 stream today.
Maybe it's not a good idea to drink caffeine.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I just need someone to do all the emote stuff.
Because I can't be bothered.
I have too much other work to do.
Every day.
The rise and grind.
Clocking in and then never clocking out.
Are they having a little fight?
I'll kill the winner.
Don't worry guys.
What the fuck?
I don't think he knows that...
When I'm invisible?
You fucking idiot.
He did it.
Come on, get over here.
Oh shit, nevermind.
I'll watch.
Thanks.
Don't worry, I'll kill that winner.
I don't think he knows that...
Invis makes it so that you can't ult me.
Which is pretty funny.
That he didn't know that.
You're a Psylocke player, you should know.
You should know not to...
Not to ult a Psylocke.
Yeah, I'm not gonna be doing too long of a stream today.
Not gonna go into the 5am queues.
Yo Doki, I got to GM playing almost nothing but Penny.
Is that rare?
Yeah, it is.
But also, GM is like...
Sort of like...
GM is Celestial.
It's sort of like the Wild Wild West.
Where like...
People are so fucking inflated.
In that ELO.
So it's like...
It's hard to actually be like...
It's hard to tell if it's like...
You got there...
As Penny because your team...
Might not be like...
Really good.
Like the enemy team just might not be really good.
Yeah, you can get to GM...
With a negative winrate.
We can get to Celestial with a negative winrate.
From what I've heard.
Which is crazy.
It's actually crazy you can get to Celestial with a negative winrate.
It's funny because a lot of people were complaining about...
Not having a rank reset.
About having a rank reset.
And not everyone was like...
Why didn't you give us a rank reset?
Look at what you did!
But it's like...
I'm just like...
But...
Like...
They were going to.
They should have though.
They 100% should have.
You have inhuman mental to DoomQ.
Negative winrate all the way to Celestial.
Some people just never stop playing.
Like...
I know there's a person...
In high elo.
All they do is just...
They would...
I don't know how they can do that.
Like...
They would just play...
They are like 1 above all.
Slash...
Uh...
High Eternity.
Like just below 1 above all.
And all they do...
They go from like...
400, 200, 400, 500, 100, 200, 400.
Like...
I don't know how you can do that.
That would fuck up my mental.
Every day.
Just going through like...
Like...
Either SR gains or SR loss.
Huge SR losses.
Per day.
And then like...
Then the next day you go into...
They go into like a huge gain.
But it's like...
Sometimes they fall all the way to like...
Uh...
What?
Like...
Eternity 100 from 500 or some shit.
And that like...
I don't know.
That's so fucking depressing.
That's so depressing.
Wait.
No Loki?
Loki is so good though.
If anything, you might as well go Mantis.
What the fuck?
Mouse feels weird.
Alright.
There you go.
Now I'm hitting.
That's so weird.
I don't know.
That...
Like...
That Groot shots were so fucking...
We soulbond here and then move up.
Like I don't know if you noticed that.
Like...
Oh yeah.
You soulbond that when you get a pick.
Cause then you can...
Cause there's no reason.
That's so...
I like miss every shot on the Groot.
And I have to like...
Shake my mouse.
And then I hit every shot.
That was so weird.
Maybe.
I've had this mouse for like...
I think...
A year...
Uh...
Hmm...
I think like...
A year and a half?
Yeah.
Maybe I just need a mental reset there for that.
But I did...
I was...
Every time I get a pick, I just like soulbond and walk forward.
Cause it makes sense.
I don't know.
Cause it's like...
Alright.
We get a pick.
Now we live forever.
Let me through!
Okay.
Nice.
Let me in!
I wanna fight!
Let's go!
Oh!
He did the thing too.
But I use mine aggressively.
Let me in!
Okay.
I have my ult though.
So I don't wanna be that aggressive.
I hope my teammate lives.
Alright.
Oh!
I hope he got some kills.
Oh.
Oh no.
I'm not there to help him.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Haha!
What are they gonna do?
Oh shit!
That's a great.
I'm a hero.
He's still alive?
How is he still alive?
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
Where the fuck is this Jeff?
Oh there he is.
Really?
I didn't hit him?
How did he fucking dodge that?
Don't worry, Luna.
I believe.
No!
Let the Luna 1v1!
Don't kill.
Bro!
What?
Okay.
Haha!
Bro!
He's trying to kill me!
Our Luna's not even healing me!
Alright.
I like stood still and then the Luna also stood still.
Like I'm still taking damage.
Like I'm still there.
I'm surprised that...
Oh.
I...
Don't know.
Don't worry.
I poor...
Oh.
Okay.
I'm a little...
I thought...
I thought more of us were alive.
I legitimately thought we had more people.
I was not counting.
I hear him.
He's like behind us.
Oh they have rocket now.
Still hear him.
The only way to counter a flanking Jeff is to ignore a flanking Jeff.
It's like just ignore his existence and it should be fine.
I know it's dumb but it's literally the play.
Cause his entire goal is to make you like turn around.
So as long as I don't look at him, he doesn't exist.
And then we lo...
And then somebody looked at him.
Somebody looked at him.
It's fine.
This is...
I don't know.
We're using so...
We're using two DPS ults.
Nice.
Where's the Jeff again?
Someone get this menace in society.
Ignore him.
Just ignore him.
He's not real.
He can't hurt you.
He's just a little guy.
What's this little guy gonna do?
He's just one small little guy.
I think our Cloak...
Goodbye Cloak.
I don't think...
Alright.
I have a feeling that...
We are...
No way!
I'm a hero!
Oh fuck.
It's okay.
I got the Luna before it all went wrong.
I don't think he knows.
You can't...
Oh my god.
This fucking sucks.
I have to reload.
I had to reload.
This fucking sucks.
I had to reload when he ate me!
It's not fair!
What happens if I...
Don't worry.
I got you!
Get out of here!
Don't worry.
I'm keeping track of everybody's HP.
So do not worry.
Don't worry.
I'm still keeping track of all your HP guys.
I'm still...
I'm still keeping track of it.
Guys.
Don't worry.
I am looking behind me.
There we go.
Okay.
How many games have you won so far?
Cause I'm on a win streak right now.
I need to...
I need to know.
How many games have you been winning?
Toki, no!
I keep forgetting that I'm still reloading.
Every time I was like...
It's like a little like...
Don't worry.
I got this.
And I'm like... I reload again.
Okay.
Chat, how many games have they lost so far?
Alright.
How many games?
Damn.
We won't win but it'll be funny.
That's rough buddy.
Zero.
But did you have fun though?
You know what's even better than having fun and losing?
Having fun and winning.
Wait, hold on.
This stupid game.
Wait.
How far did you...
Oh shit.
I can't focus.
How far did you fall?
Wait.
How far did you...
Get the fuck away from me.
I'm trying to have a conversation.
You stupid shark.
You're distracting me.
Oh shit.
There we go.
It's fine.
Oh shit.
He got the...
The Hanzo got our fucking storm.
That's unlucky.
I don't even know like what was the drop.
What's the drop?
Oh shit.
Jesus.
I'm just being pushed around right now.
I don't know what to do.
Please tank.
Push up.
That's all we want from you.
Just push up.
Are you still trying to bother me right now?
You're still trying to bother me.
Like get away from me.
What?
Not gonna lie.
I feel...
Oh, just cause I'm a cat for it.
Oh, April Fool.
I forgot April Fool ended.
I forgot guys.
Cause April Fool's ended.
It's time to say goodbye to Doe Kitty.
I'm gonna take her out back.
You can buy her.
Will you save her?
No!
Oh shit.
Let's hope.
Okay.
You did it.
I saved you.
I'm a hero.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Would I still...
Wait, do I...
Am I still in range?
No!
When I'm inside him, I don't...
Aww.
I was gonna say...
Do I heal him if I'm inside?
Don't worry.
I'm walking over as fast as I can.
I'm walking over as fast as I can guys.
I'm running away as fast as I can.
Hahaha.
Alright, we're fine.
That shark was so smart.
He like ulted me while I was doing my rez.
I don't think he likes me.
I've been like...
I've been like diffing him a little.
Oh my god, that's a rock!
Hahaha.
My map knowledge fucked me over there.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I think it's cause like I don't acknowledge him.
And then he's mad.
Like I just look at him once.
Also like...
They have been trying to challenge this Hawkeye so much.
Wait.
Where's...
Is this shark still...
Guys!
Walk forward!
It's one shark!
Just walk forward!
He can't kill us all!
What are you afraid of?
Oh Jesus, I have to use both heals for that.
It's one guy!
One tiny man!
Okay.
Soulbomb?
Don't worry, he can't die.
If he dies with a soulbomb, I would be very...
Like...
I'll be very impressed with this.
What again?
What if I just walk out of it?
Like what are you gonna do?
Nice.
Nothing.
I think that Jeff's just gonna eat my ult again.
If I like...
Shit, okay.
It's time.
Watch the Jeff go yummy yummy!
I hope you live!
It's fine, I killed him.
Nice.
That was a good trade.
That was a really good trade.
It's fine.
I'm alive.
I'm not afraid.
Okay, nice.
We lived that.
Yeah, fuck that shark.
He went to the wrong neighborhood.
I'm gonna kill this guy too.
Watch this.
He ran away.
He ran away and I closed it.
What the fuck?
You can't just run away and come back.
Either fight me or like don't fight me.
I'm literally just one guy.
A perfect being.
It's fine.
Oh shit, okay.
He actually ran for me.
Yeah, it's fine.
I was debating if I should waste my rez there.
Or just walk back.
But I don't wanna walk back.
I'm a little lazy.
Is that Iron Man?
That was Iron Man.
Stop it!
Stop!
You're just tickling me.
I don't know how people...
I don't know how people play Iron Man anymore in this elo.
He knows he's the only one that's not so bonded.
He's like...
Oh shit!
Wait, we had Cloak!
Why didn't we Cloak her?
Oh, she died.
Oh, okay.
Oh, she's always there.
Okay, that makes sense.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm here for you.
I was like...
Okay, let's go.
We can still tech...
I don't know, actually.
Can we?
Luna can.
Oh, I should've went low-key.
I don't know if they can.
Yeah.
That shark actually saved them.
That was such a good...
Stomp by them.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I'm just gonna run.
Yeah, that bubble was insane.
I don't know if I should...
No, I should just die.
What's with this Jeff?
That's how Jeff plays.
But he's not like...
particularly the best flanking Jeff I've seen.
Because he doesn't actually kill.
He's just really, really annoying.
Honestly.
I don't see him as incredibly annoying.
But he does not make...
He doesn't really do much for the team.
I just see him as incredibly annoying.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I didn't think it'd be two of them.
Let's see.
Did I grab them?
I don't know if I did.
There we go.
Oh, did I get everybody?
Nah.
Okay.
I'll try to see if I can grab.
Oh.
Unlucky.
Alright, give me a sec.
And then...
So I can go for him.
There we go.
Guys, we have to...
Please!
Why do we keep leaving our...
Our tanks for one little guy?
The fact that we...
Please.
It's literally one shark.
Why are we so scared of him?
Literally everybody turned around for the shark.
And then we left her.
We...
We left her strange again.
Oh, we did.
I did.
I claimed the...
I claimed it.
There's another Nintendo Direct?
What do they just get a Nintendo Direct?
I'm surprised.
We got another one.
Okay, guys.
Let's not all turn around for the Jeff.
Oh, is this for the Switch too?
I don't know.
Because I do have a 1230 stream.
I don't know if I want to wake up...
Wake up even earlier.
I'm not that type of person to be fair.
Oh, let's go.
It's literally...
Like our team just needs to ignore him.
He's literally...
He's not doing as much as they think he's doing.
He has 810.
He has 10 deaths and 8 kills.
All he does is just be a fucking nuisance.
But we killed the entire team and then we killed Jeff.
Or one person killed Jeff.
Here we go.
Oh, portal.
Except for the Jeff.
That's just...
Okay, I don't have...
Bad target set.
Okay, I don't have snaps now.
So I have to use Soul Bond if they need help.
Oh my god, really?
I have to use...
No!
My Soul Bond didn't work.
Fuck.
That sucked.
I'm not wasting Soul Bond.
Oh, I got deleted too fast.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna...
Guys, it's because Gomez jumped in and then...
They rubbed their last streak on him.
He gave the curse.
Guys, I was stomping.
Not gonna lie.
Okay.
Was my team not fucking stomping hard though?
Were they not, guys?
Okay, this is bad.
Oh, this is very bad.
We have no support ults for this.
And I already used my Soul Bond.
Oh my god, are you serious?
No!
And then we used Cloak!
I don't know.
That's really bad for us.
Because I don't even have...
Okay.
I'm trying.
I'm trying my best.
Okay, we have to back out.
There's no way.
We have to back out and live this one.
We can rez here.
I cannot rez this.
No.
Oh, I can't.
He's too far.
He's way too far.
Oh my god, I can't do anything.
That Jeff ulted really well.
He was so far!
He died so ahead.
That's unlucky.
Oh no.
There, Jeff did a really good ult there.
And we died too ahead.
I don't...
No.
Alright, go up.
Go up!
Go up, I soulbonded.
Why are you scared?
Okay.
Oh, they all got off.
Oh my god.
I was like, what are you guys doing?
Just run!
Get out there!
Alright.
I'm gonna go lowkey.
Actually, I don't know.
Against Jeff?
Against Jeff...
Adam and lowkey are both good.
For Jeff.
But like...
I think we might need three support ults.
Three support ults is better than two support ults.
My team has been not getting support ults.
I don't know.
I feel like I've been doing a lot damaging wise too.
I've been getting kills as well.
No, I can't play flanker Jeff.
I don't know the tech.
I'm not good with doing the tech stuff.
I feel like I've been contributing in damage too.
So, I don't know.
I'm better at killing Jeff on Adam than I am on lowkey.
Cause his is more hitscan.
Oh...
Fuck.
Alright, if we lose this is my fault cause I'm lowkey.
I should have been on...
If we lose this...
No, actually I'm gonna go Adam.
We have two flyers.
I'm gonna go Adam.
Just cause like...
It's easier...
It's easier to heal.
There we go.
That strange is...
Trying to survive.
Good for you.
I'm trying to keep track of...
The people who needs heals behind us.
You're fine.
Alright.
Don't worry, you're fine.
So, I have to use this but you should be fine.
You're fine.
We need to get a kill with that soulbond but that's...
Oh, that's fine.
Yep.
That can be our kill.
Alright.
Oh...
That was a good inbound though.
Please!
There's literally a mag in front of us!
Alright.
I don't have soulbond.
Oh, that's fine.
I'm just gonna reload.
Before I do this.
I'll just reload in front of them, it's fine.
Alright.
Jeff is just gonna try and eat us all.
So...
Scary!
Woah!
Scary Jeff!
He's gonna try and eat us all!
I don't know what to do about that!
Whoops!
Almost knocked myself out!
Just gonna try and knock us out!
Oh.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, nice, nice!
We got him.
Nice.
That's fine.
He knows I'm there now!
Alright.
What if I...
Nice.
I actually...
Oh no, this is bad.
Oh, this is okay.
Oh no!
That's fine.
Guys, guys!
Guys!
Nice.
Where?
Okay.
Their Jeff is coming over for a good yummy yummy.
Which is very worrisome right now.
Their Jeff's looking for it.
Their Jeff is looking for it right now.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
That's fine.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Please live, please live, please live, please live.
Oh my god, he lives!
Okay.
Okay, he lives.
Thank god.
I was a little worried.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh!
There's the shark.
Please kill the shark!
Oh!
Kill him!
Alright, we did it.
Oh my god.
That was scary.
I was like, don't stream!
Just live stream!
Just live!
Nice!
Thank you for the dollars!
Thank you!
And Piri, thank you for the ring!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, my heart was beating fast there.
Oh my god.
My heart was beating so fast.
That was a game.
Let me check something real quick.
What's the record?
I'm currently...
He almost cursed me.
If they win their next game...
If they win their next game, guys...
If they...
If they win...
I'm avoiding their Jeff.
Their Jeff was like, just fucking annoying.
And he doesn't do jack shit.
He's getting up!
Did they lose their last game?
What's going on?
They won?
Do I really want to end the win streak?
Oh, you're so right.
You're so...
You're so right.
Oh shit!
Whoops.
I forgot.
Whenever I type, I forgot.
That was like the only thing I turned on.
It was my fish.
Wait, which one was my fish again?
I forgot which one it was.
Which one was the button for my fish?
Oh my god, I don't remember.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum.
I don't remember.
Oh, it's this one.
Oh yeah.
It's this one.
You know what that means.
I'm hungry.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
For those who are like, what's their record?
What their record is.
This is...
This is their...
What's my record?
Well, it looks beautiful.
Look at my record, guys.
Wow, what a beautiful record.
Now let's look over to this other record over there.
Let's see what the problem is.
Let's see what the problem is over there.
I think the color is reversed.
I'm surprised they even got...
Okay.
Alright, we'll cut a deal.
We'll cut a deal.
The moment...
I lose my win streak...
I'll play.
So I'll have nothing to lose.
No more.
You guys can't wait that long.
We'll do it next time.
And then...
I will be willing to commit a full loss streak with you guys.
Sniper!
And then...
And then, I'll be willing...
If we lose four to five games...
Don't worry.
I'm willing to commit to this account.
They waited 20...
I didn't tell them to wait!
I was playing my game!
I was in my own game!
What do you mean?
How is that my fault that they waited 20 minutes?
Toki, it's your fault.
Help him.
I didn't even know they were waiting!
I like how someone's like, If they can wait 20 minutes, they can wait 20 minutes more.
Then...
Then, don't worry.
Next time...
If you guys can't wait...
The next time...
I can commit throughout the loss streaks.
Damn.
You're so cruel.
What did I do?
Alright.
Or you can snipe me.
Snipe me.
You guys are low enough, right?
Are you guys low enough?
Don't worry, let's snipe each other.
I'll do a countdown.
You guys are low enough now, right?
Alright.
3...
2...
1...
Let's go.
Bro, that's messed...
What?
I'm ready.
Wouldn't it be crazy if we did get into each other?
That would be fucking crazy.
Imagine...
Oh, then it's freelo.
Freelo.
Alright, let's see.
Karmas, thank you for the 300 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Vaan, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
I would literally cry at your what pranksters loss streak.
I give it and I take it.
Okay, QOD what?
Okay, okay, okay.
Here.
Here you go.
We'll see how it goes.
Alright, let me do my...
You can snipe me in Doom matches too.
Let's go.
I can't believe you guys waited 20 minutes.
Alright.
Let's see.
Don't worry, I'm in Oregon Doom matches too.
Snipe me there as well if you can.
Alright.
Are these real people in my Doom matches?
Listen.
Oh, no they're not.
No, they're not.
They definitely...
Oh fuck.
Oh shit.
I gotta run.
Oh no.
No, Starly you don't understand.
I fucked up.
I fucked up Starly.
You don't understand.
Run.
Oh no.
Okay, I'm safe right now.
Okay, oh no.
You don't know where I actually am.
You're in Grave Danger.
It's okay, we're safe.
Oh, what the fuck?
Goodbye.
Disappear.
Run.
You don't know.
I've disappeared.
Oh shit.
Disappear.
No.
I refuse to believe it wasn't stream sniping chat.
That had to be stream sniping.
There's no way.
I can't believe it.
Stream sniping in my Doom match?
That's crazy.
It's like hide and seek right now.
Where am I?
Whoa.
I think I'm safe guys.
I think I'm safe.
I feel like there's barely anyone playing in Oregon server.
I barely ever get games in Oregon.
I feel like there's almost zero games in this server in general.
Oh, they got a game.
They got a game!
They got a game.
Alright, you know what that means.
Getting out of Oregon.
I won a fucking game.
I feel like I, yeah, I like never.
I like get like one West Coast server every like 10 games.
Yeah, they're gone.
I was like, they actually did disappear.
Oh my god.
They're gone.
Alright, back into my Doom matches.
I feel like there's like not a lot of servers in...
Oh.
I was like...
Oh, I didn't see this guy over there.
I feel like there's not a lot of...
Wait.
Who's that?
What the fuck?
Who's Dookie's cat ears?
Who the fuck was that?
Wait, who the fuck was in that Doom match?
Who's that guy?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
I have several people trying to snipe me now.
They just debuted today.
I was here to count already.
They just came out today.
Dookie, he only existed like a couple of hours ago.
Are we roleplaying?
We're watching a shark 1v1.
Ooh, it's the sharkiest shark of all.
Alright, we killed a winner.
There's no true winners in the Jeff fight.
You dude was wait...
I think he was waiting for me to show up and then he literally got a game the moment I showed up.
That's so fucked up.
Hello, little guy.
Which one is the emote button in Rivalous anyway?
Which one is it?
Oh, a T?
Is it a T?
Oh!
Whoa, I've never used emotes before in Rivalous.
I hope they have actual...
good skins soon for supports.
Like I said, I feel like the only good support skin so far is the present Loki.
I don't like...
I don't know.
Not a fan of any of the other support skins.
Yeah.
I feel like the other...
Like, I feel like DPS and tanks have better skins than supports.
Like, none of them are good.
Bounty Hunter...
Rocket's not a...
Rocket...
If I...
How can I say this without getting my Twitch demonetized?
What can I say about Rocket?
You don't...
He's actually...
Okay, the worst part is that...
He's actually really, really good in the higher, higher ELO.
Like...
In...
Let's see.
In like, one above all lobbies now.
But like, people who got inflated...
Got inflated SR games with Rocket...
Do not play at that level.
They are not good.
They do not play at that level.
I feel like...
Rocket 1 tricks are not good at beating high, low...
High ELO Rocket players.
I've encountered...
Players who play...
Support mains who play Rocket really, really well.
But not Rocket 1 tricks who play Rocket really, really well.
Like, I know like a couple of support players that can live on Rocket for so long.
Yeah, they just have game sense from playing other supports.
So like, that translates well into Rocket.
But like, I don't know.
We haven't killed each other yet.
Like...
What's wrong?
How have I not found a dead king?
How...
How have like...
People with high...
Ooh.
Let's go.
Oh shit, sorry.
I got spanked at, sorry.
I couldn't help myself.
I...
I couldn't...
I couldn't help myself.
Oh shit!
No!
He didn't want to share.
Holy shit.
Smacked that.
But...
Oh, he's mine.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I'm...
Am I roleplaying?
I'm doing it, guys.
I'm roleplaying.
I'm doing it.
Alright.
What lobby is this?
I mean, it's just low eternity.
Like I said, I feel like there's barely any west coast servers.
I think they like...
They put all the servers in east coast.
Oh.
Okay, I wanna play...
Hmm.
Alright,
I'm banning...
I wanna say, you know what?
Fuck Luna.
You know you're right.
Today's a non-Luna day.
It's a non-Luna day today.
Oh, we're banning Luna.
We're banning...
Hmm.
Hello.
I'mma ban Groot.
We don't have a Groot player anyway.
Yay!
They banned Hello.
Alright, goodbye Groot.
Goodbye.
They have a low-key player, by the way, if we wanna ban him.
It's okay.
We have the low-key player.
Five star eight.
Nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright.
I'mma play Seastorm.
For the thing anyway.
Yeah.
I put streamer mode on because I get tired of...
People...
I don't know.
People are weird.
So I just put streamer mode on.
Ah, buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh.
You're looking sound a bit tired.
I'mma play like...
I'mma say today's anime is short.
I wish I did start a stream earlier.
I just had a lot of work to do.
And I do have an early stream tomorrow too.
I'll stream at 1230 tomorrow.
I still wanted to stream a little bit of Rivals.
Because, you know, I do have like...
I don't wanna like...
I don't wanna like put too many...
Like, force myself to stream in big batches.
Uh...
In big batches before the deadline.
So I just... I can do like tiny batches too.
And our games have been going well.
How's this?
We play until we lose.
I'mma say that and then we lose this next game.
Hi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're gonna be so...
Why are we so split up like that?
I just followed our match.
It was so funny.
And we like...
Lost right here.
Okay, we play until we lose two games.
Oh yeah, we're definitely...
We're definitely playing until we lose two games.
We're...
Yeah, I started thinking that.
And I was like, I'm very...
Very...
What time is it over there?
And you...
Dox yourself.
Cause I don't remember which...
Which EU.
It's like 10 AM.
Wait, why the fuck are you awake at 10?
What the fuck?
You have to study?
Aww.
Why study when you can play Rivals?
Think about it.
Guys, I don't think we're winning this.
Guys, I don't think we're...
Oh my...
It's fucking...
Okay.
Um...
Yeah.
If we fucked up, it would be like...
Oh shit, wait.
Oh shit, I couldn't...
I did have push.
I was just not paying attention.
There you go.
But I did pull him!
Look at that.
It's okay.
There's still hope.
Control C!
Oh my god, Healers.
Yeah, Healers.
A little bit of Rivals won't hurt you, right?
This account is a hundred and...
A hundred and...
Twenty something?
I think?
This is 120.
Guys, there's like a guy over the top there.
Feeling fantastic.
Okay.
It's fine.
Come on, you...
It would be so fun to like...
You know, oh my god, just think about it.
Getting on Rivals.
Getting yelled at by like NA people because they talk too much.
Is that your favorite part of the day?
Wouldn't you wanna...
Come on!
You know you want it.
Don't you wanna get yelled at?
By NA people?
Actually no, more like...
Actually I can tell.
I don't know who yells more.
EU or NA.
NA people just talk a lot.
EU people will wait until you fuck up and then...
And then just like tell you...
Say I'll fuck your mom.
Or some shit.
Or say your mom is disappointed in you.
They talk less talk.
Don't wait until you fuck up.
Okay.
Yeah, EU is saying rage.
No, I agree.
Oh shit.
Oh that's bad.
Do we have rez?
We do.
NA people love to talk.
It's like our thing.
Even if it's like...
Oh no!
And then the stage walked up to me!
I'm so fucked up!
I actually did a game winning play!
Oh my god.
The world hates me.
This is my villain arc right here.
Okay, don't worry.
They can't hurt you now.
Oh my god!
First stage!
Yes!
I don't...
I don't think we're winning this one.
I'm first stage!
He won!
He got...
He got Kalooge.
I just gave up after this.
You're not gonna try and re...
What?
Oh my god.
We got our first stage!
What are we doing?
Why are we falling for that?
I guess we were right at his feet, so...
Ranged is gonna die, but like...
We got kidnapped!
You have to put it at exact...
Oh my god.
He even jumped on it too, because you can't...
Okay.
Okay, I might go...
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I wanna go lowkey, because...
I don't know we have enough heals right now.
I don't...
Like, I don't understand why you would jump through that, man.
Makes no sense.
We got this.
Damn.
You hear that?
We got this.
That's crazy.
Alright, if we lose this, we get one more loss before...
Before things go out of hand.
Yeah, he did.
That was crazy.
Seeing him jump through this.
Is it Visor or somebody?
I don't remember.
That name is familiar.
Or maybe I just play too much.
And everybody's familiar at this time.
At least they're confident.
Can we just make this and go at them?
I don't think they have any...
Oh, please!
Okay.
I don't know, but...
I guess we don't go at them.
I think it was Karma.
I think it may or may not be Karma.
Is he in Nightmare?
Yeah, I think so, right?
That name is familiar.
How is he...
Wait, how did he drop down here?
Does that mean...
Everybody has bad days, guys.
It happens to all of us.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna be like...
Is that his main or is it just Visor?
I don't remember.
I don't remember if his main was...
Woah!
Don't worry, he's not gonna gen us, right?
Oh, nevermind.
Okay, let's go.
Let's save...
Oh, no, Loki!
Loki, no!
I wanted to save you!
It's fine.
It's not fine.
We're so back.
We're still...
I have to reload, but we're still so back.
We're so back.
We're so healthy.
It's okay.
I'm healing so much through everything.
At least we're stabilized, right?
Feeling good!
Nice, okay.
Woah, okay, goodbye prison rules.
Clearly prison didn't help him.
Goodbye, into the pit you go.
No!
I thought that was so cool.
Don't worry, I'll put you back in that pit.
I'll put you back.
He bubbled.
That's unlucky.
We're gonna lose this.
100%.
I don't know.
I don't feel very confident.
I don't feel very confident right now.
I'll put it right here.
Yeah, that's...
I need to figure out...
I need to push that better.
I need to like...
Jesus Christ, like where is he?
Oh my god!
How did I get double...
Did they double two?
They like double sued us!
Oh my god.
I got double pushed out.
Oh my...
I was like...
Get me back in here!
Oh no.
No, that's karma.
That's karma right there.
I deserved it.
I showed his record.
I showed it to the whole world to see.
I showed it.
Alright.
Wait, have you been watching again?
Okay.
We saw...
We saw the...
What do you mean?
Oh shit!
Yum yum yum yum yum yum yum.
I need a fish break.
Yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum.
I'm in a fish break.
Yum yum yum.
Alright.
It's a winning stock.
We're going in.
Wait, why was the queue canceled?
Oh my god!
Wait, do you want to join Discord real quick?
What?
I thought you need pizza.
Why?
Wait.
I don't have...
Wait, I don't have push to talk.
Do I have push to talk?
Wait, they're talking to us in-game.
I can talk in-game.
The rest of the team is like...
The rest of the team is just like...
What the fuck are they talking about?
Okay, I banned Hella.
Right?
Thank you Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
And I become a cat.
April Fool.
I just...
I killed her.
It's DoeKitty's channel now.
You know what they say about cats and birds.
It's time.
Discord or no Discord.
We can...
We're here.
We can talk in-game.
Let me bind...
My mic.
The rest of the team is like...
It's like...
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, they banned Luna.
That's fine.
It's Loki time.
Who do I copy?
Okay.
Okay, never...
I was gonna say like...
Who do I copy?
I guess none of them.
Alright.
Let's see.
In-game voice volume.
Push to talk.
Voice chat mic.
Communication.
Oh, I have it on.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I just copied...
Oh, you're right.
What would be better than one rocket?
Two rockets.
Keep the loot streak going.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, oh my god.
Double...
Imagine.
Double ampli...
Oh my god, I should do that.
Okay, when I die, I'm gonna play Loki.
And then we're gonna double amplify and then I'll swap back to Sue.
I get one.
This mic is so quiet.
Yeah, no, they stack.
No, they do.
Wait, they don't?
I was lied to!
I thought they stack!
Oh my god, what's the point if they don't stack?
What's the point?
That was my whole mission.
I can't believe it.
I got lied to.
I thought they stack.
What do I do?
Now that I know it doesn't stack, like, what do I do?
My life is over.
I feel like I have to be here.
I have to actually, like, frontline.
It's okay, our Loki can heal.
I'll just heal here.
Are they okay?
They're okay.
They'll be fine.
They're so healthy!
My team's dead in the front.
Whoops.
They're so healthy still.
I believe.
What?
Hey guys.
I wish...
I wish I had...
I don't know.
I wish I had, like, uh...
Oh wait, wait, we can...
He's so healthy.
He's so... he's dead.
But he'll be healthy.
I believe.
I still believe.
Look, I got scared.
Look, we did it.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
We're so healthy.
Okay, I ulted first, so, like, it's our rocket's fault.
I threw that ult first.
Alright.
I did it.
I fucking did it, guys.
I'm a hero.
Will I die?
No.
I wouldn't.
I'm gaming.
Okay, I...
am a little worried.
Hmm...
Maybe I should've...
Eh...
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
What?!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
That was so...
Oh my god!
He just shot general direction and it got me!
Okay, but what if I go low-key?
You know what?
No, I should...
No...
Yes.
Let's do it.
I was like, no!
But yes!
No!
Alright.
And then I copy...
I fucked up.
I might've fucked up a little bit.
Because I'm supposed to be on high ground.
But I'm like stuck down here.
I'm supposed to be on high ground but I'm still down here.
Don't worry.
Everybody is so healthy.
Oh my god!
You know what would be better than one amplifier?
Watch this.
Oh my god!
Double rez!
This is it.
Please!
Oh my god!
Okay, I might've threw there.
Okay, we won't do that again.
Alright.
Alright guys.
I realized that like...
Maybe copying a rocket was not it.
Guys!
I'm not trolling, guys.
I was just...
I was experimenting.
There we go.
What?
I was just experimenting.
I was theorycrafting, okay?
Oh, that is unfair.
Unlucky.
That is actually so unlucky.
That is very unlucky.
Alright.
Loki's not it, guys.
Go back.
Alright, I'm done trolling.
I'm done trolling.
I'm done trolling, guys.
Guys, look.
I'm playing the game.
Look.
Okay, nice.
It's fine.
Look at that.
I'm doing it.
I'm doing it, guys.
They're so healthy.
Okay, I don't know what to do for these guys though.
Nice, okay.
Wow.
Wait, the game got easier.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
The game got a little bit easier.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
We all live.
I'm okay.
It's okay.
I'll just stay around here.
I'll just stay on my orb.
Jesus Christ.
What's going on down there?
Oh, shit!
Wait, this game actually got easier when I'm not on Loki.
Alright.
Look, we needed a little bit of spice in there, okay?
The game would've been too easy if I didn't...
If I didn't go Loki for one game.
For one time.
Who is that?
Games get easier when you're fucking around.
Who would've thought?
Yeah.
We could...
Or, Loki, I don't know.
You could try to do double amplify again.
It could be different.
Oh my god, double fantastical.
Imagine.
Oh my god, you're so...
You're so...
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait, we could do that.
They won't know.
That's the best part.
It could be better on attackers.
Double fantastical.
Let's go.
If we lose...
None of us are on our mains.
It's fine.
Literally, none of us are on our mains.
It's okay.
They won't know.
Double the bounce.
Oh my god, you're so right.
It's okay.
They don't know that.
No, I'm pretty sure they all...
Maybe they're all...
Maybe we're all on our ult accounts, guys.
We could all be on our ult accounts.
Double the bounce.
Double the fun.
Okay.
Okay, but...
Rocket players don't have rates.
So, like, I don't need...
It's...
We just need to care about the two other players.
In our game.
I just need to know what the two other players think.
It's fine.
I don't really...
I'm not even looking back.
I don't know if you noticed that.
Not even...
I'm not looking behind me.
About whatever the fucking Sarlord was trying to do.
Oh, is he...
Wait, he tried to shoot the clone!
That's cute.
What's wrong with playing Rocket?
Everything.
Okay, nice.
Double the bounce.
Double the fun.
Alright, I almost have it.
Guys, please don't...
Okay, here.
They're gonna get over here, right?
I don't have Envron right now.
I wasted that.
But they don't know that.
You can say that I was being a hero right now.
Oh, I almost have it, guys!
I almost have it!
Oh my god, it's almost time.
It's almost time.
I'm heading over.
I'm ready to copy him.
I'm ready.
Get over...
No!
My bounce!
I couldn't even get the low key!
I got robbed of the double bounce.
We were so close.
They were getting too much.
Because I'm dead tired and pizza and my boss.
What's wrong?
Weak.
Pizza, come play.
I'll join VC and let you throw.
Every time I win.
Bad friend.
Who the fuck is Doki's cat ears?
Wait, I need to...
Let's go.
Reject.
Yoink.
Here we go.
Let's go.
I don't even have pizzas to scream.
I lied.
Masterfully done.
Look at that.
And that's how you guys...
And that's how you kidnap players.
Excellent.
See guys?
I told you I was gonna kidnap a player.
I did it.
I kidnapped Taco onto my stack.
Our duo now.
It's that easy.
It's just...
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
See?
My title wasn't a lie.
Managed to kidnap somebody to join me.
She's actually so good at this.
Yoink.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh wait, they invited me to the Discord.
Wait, they just invited me to the Discord?
I think they did.
I won't talk to you guys any longer.
Or maybe I'll just lie and be...
She's done this before.
Please show me your ways.
Just call the other duo weak and then take the one that's still strong.
Just don't take the weak one.
It's just that easy.
You call one of them weak and then the other duo will be like, Wait, I'm not weak.
And then now they're in your team.
Hello, are we roleplaying?
Wait, can you talk in these match ads?
Oh, you can.
How much?
Oh my god, it's just like the Overwatch...
It's just like the Overwatch RP series.
Right there.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, two for one?
Let's go, smack that.
I'm just...
I'm just smacking.
Wait, no!
The butt.
I didn't know there was a no touch rule.
I didn't know...
No touching.
I didn't know.
Can't touch the merchandise.
Yeah, he's his own bouncer.
Wait.
Oh shit, wait, he's in here.
Oops.
Just like in real life, can't touch for free, alright.
I can watch but no touch, apparently.
Let's go.
Wait, can I swap characters?
No, I have to die to swap.
Oh my god.
Would it be wrong?
Okay, there's one character I want to swap to, but it might be wrong.
Wait, I'm sorry, I was enjoying...
Oh!
I'm sorry, I'm enjoying this.
I'm sorry, please keep smacking.
I love this emote.
Truly is one of the best emotes out there.
No, I was gonna...
I don't know.
Maybe I could.
Okay, is there like a pit I could fall through?
Wait, I just need them to kill me.
Game mode.
Honestly, the fact that it's for free is actually crazy.
I can't...
People would actually pay like hundreds of thousands of dollars for this fucking emote.
So the fact that this emote is free is actually criminal.
There's a pit in dining room?
Where's the dining room?
I don't know this area very well.
Actually don't know.
Okay, that's outside.
That's also outside.
Wait, is that the dining?
Oh, there it is.
Right here.
Alright.
Wait, that's not...
This is not the pit?
It's not it?
Oh, I lied.
People lie on the internet like that?
Oh, just like how I'm lying the pizza that I was gonna join VC?
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
People that's not me also lie?
That's crazy.
Wait, how am I mean?
How am I mean, guys?
Does this look like a face that's a mean...
That's...
That's a bad kitty?
Haha.
Hahaha.
Yes.
Very bad.
100%.
Holy shit.
Where are these queue times?
That's a crazy...
That's a crazy queue time.
Is this normal?
Is this a normal queue time at these hours?
It's like 1...
It's only 1.30.
It's only 1.30 AM.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Good game.
Maybe I need to stop doing DJIN hours so I can actually get games and lobbies.
Oh my god.
Is it back to ROBLOX hours?
Is it...
Haha.
Is it time?
Alright.
Alright, guys.
If the queue time goes to...
It's...
Exactly!
It's only 1.30!
How are queue times that bad?
It's only 1.30.
Oh.
Okay.
I was gonna say.
I was gonna pull up the ROBLOX.
Oh, true.
4.30.
Oh, hey.
There's Seor Raz again.
There he is.
They do not want me playing ROBLOX.
Alright.
I wanna...
Okay, not throw it.
I'm not gonna throw it, guys.
But what if...
We do it again?
Now that he's not here to stop me.
What if we do that...
What if we try to do that again?
And...
No!
Don't kid me!
Oh, it's not the low-key pick that's throwing.
It's what I wanna do with my ult.
Alright, let's see.
Yeah, we have to ban Wolverine because we have a Groot.
Alright.
It's time.
Oh, I could go...
Sue.
It'll make this easier.
Silver!
Thank you for Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
And Marco, thank you for the gift to your oneself.
Do something...
Do something fun?
You do something fun, right?
I think that's Pizza.
I don't think he knows who Pizza is.
Eating pizza, swap off, you fucking numbnut.
What the fuck?
Bro, they don't know who Pizza is?
Like, is he really the only guy that can make Mr. Fantastic work?
Guys, I don't think he'll...
Guys, I don't think I can copy Mr...
I think...
I think our Groot is one bad day...
One bad day away.
Guys, I...
I legitimately believe he's one bad day away.
I don't think I can copy Pizza, guys.
I don't think...
Oh, he is 100...
It would be so good.
He is 100% one...
One bad day from something happening.
Jesus Christ, I have to reload, please.
Luna.
Oh my god, Luna.
Please.
I have to reload.
No!
I actually lost my ult.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I lost my ult, sis.
That was bad.
I was too cocky there.
I don't know if we can...
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, that...
That portal was not it.
How do you put clones up here?
Like, I don't...
Am I gonna break this?
Yeah, okay.
I was gonna say, I don't know where is the best place to put clones here.
Maybe I should go Sue.
Maybe...
Guys, I don't want...
I don't want him to yell at me.
The crashout is very imminent.
I can feel it.
I can feel it, guys.
I can feel the bad day coming in.
I...
Oh shit.
Got me out of invis too.
The whole kit.
Nice.
Guys, I...
I'm sorry, I didn't have invuln.
I'm sorry.
I didn't have...
Okay.
It's time.
Don't worry.
Now it's time to actually focus up a little.
Oh my god.
Enemy is always like this.
He doesn't even change how he's mean.
Wow.
I didn't have push.
Oh my god.
Today...
I think it's today, guys.
I think today...
Guys, I think today is his bad day, guys.
I...
I think it's today.
Oh my god.
It's today.
Today is the bad day.
It's gonna happen.
It's fine.
Okay, I have to do that.
Everybody was so low.
Damn.
We're gonna witness the biggest...
We're gonna witness the crash out.
I swear to god.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
Everything is so...
It's not today.
It's literally right now.
We're experiencing it live.
It's not even here!
You finally fucking speak.
Are you serious?
It broke!
It's not even in this game!
It's cause he...
It's cause he sees pizza!
Bro!
He doesn't know I...
I stole...
I stole his duo.
I see...
It's not even here.
How is he like...
That's crazy.
I can't.
Not again!
Bro, he's beefing with ghosts right now.
He's sniffing shanties.
The current score is...
0-2-3 Time to switch things up.
I'm winning.
I got my hand on it, bro.
I'm ready.
I'm monitoring my fucking feet.
Give me that shit right now.
I'm not the type who fits quietly into the background.
I'm still a fantastic buddy.
I got my hand on the button.
He's arguing with actual demons right now.
Oh my god, wait, it's Sakura!
For fuck's sakes, do you even play Fantastic?
Yes, he does!
What do you mean?
He does that every day!
I'm so miserable.
Bro, I want to fucking cry right now.
I've lost 10 million subscribers playing you in fucking Fantastic.
These guys have world record time on us.
They have three fucking minutes.
I've never seen that before.
Like, we're just doomed.
Man, I want to fucking cry, dude.
Because every game I play, I don't want to fucking kill myself.
Well, no, it's not you in general.
But, like, why the fuck are you playing Fantastic?
You didn't even play that.
You didn't even play Fantastic, dude.
Like, do you even play that shit?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I promise, holy shit, dude.
I do have to change my voice.
No, you don't.
You sound like you got your nose plugged firm again.
Fuck's sakes.
Let's be serious here.
Let's not do this.
Gomez, Gomez had to fucking dip.
You made him lose 200 SR.
And I just played Fantastic.
Oh my god, bro.
You were tripping with Gomez on the rop camp.
For fuck's sakes.
Now you're just fucking doing everything, dude.
Oh my goodness.
You're even on fucking Fantastic.
You're like, you're just great.
Did you get off Fantastic?
I love Marvel Rivals, guys.
Hey, guys.
How was your day?
Why does this always happen?
Why is this my duo?
I got 10 yesterday.
How about that?
Yeah, I'm pretty full of it.
Holy shit.
You're throwing for fucking Mei, aren't you, Bob?
What the fuck?
What is he throwing for?
It's okay, guys.
Disappear.
It's okay.
We should be fine, right?
Oh, he's so...
He's alive.
There we go.
See, we should be fine.
I need a push.
I'm so like not used to it.
Oh god, I'm so...
Oh god, okay.
I'm like so not used to using my push for it.
I'm not good enough.
Oh no.
Oh no, please.
Please.
Where's our 10 gifted?
Guys, he's crashing.
I love these people who get paid to throw my games.
This shit's awesome.
Go, bro.
Pizza's not the problem, bro.
Thought you wouldn't see me again.
It's because I sound miserable.
That's why we don't like pizza.
Our enemies are here.
Guys, now you know I was hesitant above the three stars.
I've seen their journey.
Bro, this guy's going through it, guys.
Guys, he's so...
Guys, this is not a good day for him.
Guys,
they don't know what I'm doing.
Okay, my reputation is okay.
I didn't make a guy about to crash out.
I'm just saying, like, if I didn't kidnap pizza, he would not have fucking about to...
He would not have encountered Sakura going through the worst day of his life right now.
Oh my god.
Guys, it's not my fault.
Oh my god, I'm trying to save you, buddy.
Oh my god.
Guys.
In the end, it may or may not be my fault that I brought pizza into Sakura's world.
It may or may...
It may or may not be my fault that I did that.
I might have... I might have ruined somebody today.
April Fools, April Fools.
What?
I hope we get them on the enemy team.
I hope I get Sakura on the enemy team and buy a miracle.
I hope that somehow my team wins so I can witness the crash out.
Crash out 2.0.
That is the dream.
Hey, I received an upvote!
He doesn't know!
Sakura gave me an upvote!
Let's go!
I got an upvote from Sakura!
No, he's not a group main.
He's actually... He's a strange main.
I know, because I know Sakura from the first season.
Oh, is it him?
Oh my god!
I'm still sorry I went with Bangroot just because I don't like playing against Groot.
Oh, it is?
Okay.
We ban Adam?
I'll do Adam, then Groot then.
Because we have a Hella and a Neymar player.
Hello?
Oh, he's back.
Okay.
Hello?
Alright.
I'll have to go Luna for it.
It's so funny.
They think, like...
They think he's, like... They ban Starlord because he's fighting his demons right now.
Like...
He doesn't know pizzas with me right now.
So he's banning Starlord because Gomez plays Starlord.
And he thinks it's a Pizza Gomez duo right now.
But he doesn't know I'm the one that yoinked him.
Hahaha.
We take this.
He's actually fighting his demons.
Alright.
Alright, I'll give it to Pizza.
April Fools!
I...
It would be great if we win this.
Just for the sake of the crashout.
I want to know what he'll say.
Like...
Like, we're giving him... Today's his... It takes one bad day.
And that's... Today is... It's happening right now.
We're watching it right now.
I don't know who to give it to.
Because we have Hela and Namor.
And then that's, like, both, like, good.
They're both good flanking characters.
I don't know who's gonna flank more.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh, I need a reload.
Oh, please.
Please.
Please!
He's missing so much!
Oh my...
Oh, I thought I could.
That's crazy.
He actually missed so much.
Wait.
He's just...
1v5...
1v3ing them.
Is he...
Oh my god.
How is he...
What the fuck is going on?
What the...
Bro, wasn't there, like, five people over there?
Oh, okay.
They're dead.
I was so confused.
And he was not taking any damage.
What was going...
He's just missing...
Can you hear me?
Okay, my mic's working.
That's good.
True, true.
He has to eat one person.
He ate nothing.
Oh my god!
Wait, he's not here!
No!
You know he's...
Imsikuro was...
Was in our game right now.
He would 100% say something about...
He would have said something about our fucking...
Shit.
I'm fine.
About the shark.
100%.
I feel it.
I fucked...
Okay, nice.
That's fine.
Go!
Pizza!
Do your thing, pizza!
Go, pizza!
Go!
You know what?
You deserve this.
You fucking deserve this.
Oh, I would never lose this.
Now you would go...
Is that Sakura?
From last game?
Oh, maybe they banned pizza because he thought the enemy team actually did that.
Is that him?
Are you okay?
That was a pretty rough game.
Sorry for...
Sorry.
Where are you though?
I'll never tell.
Oh shit.
Hello?
Wait, how am I still don't have ult yet?
I guess I'll just die?
Unless...
No, I definitely would just die.
I definitely would just die.
Someone needs a snowball in the cake.
Be strong together.
Alright, things are okay.
Why would I need you?
Everything is okay.
I do not know how fucking pizza...
He plays like every fucking off-meta shit possible and just makes it work.
Except for tank, like...
Never put that man on tank.
I like the clothes.
Sakura, you want a trio queue?
Haha.
Could be pizza.
On your main.
What is wrong?
Okay, do you remember when I said like...
Tank players are masochists?
Like, that's what I mean.
I'd rather...
I'd rather live.
That's nice.
I was not paying attention to what he was saying.
I was like, what did he say?
Was that damage?
I hope it was.
Oh, you know he's gonna play fantastic.
I think he'd be like, 10 gifted and we'll let you trio...
Fuck!
There's no way he'll shoot.
Okay, I need to watch this.
Oh my god.
Why would he shoot the whole...
I hear the fucking freeze.
That's a hate crime.
There was like, four options.
There were four fucking options.
Why not shoot?
You're right.
There's a hole, there's a goal.
Where the fuck is...
You know, him throwing a hissy fit.
Wait, that's what I told you guys.
Tank players are masochists.
That guy was there, he's like...
He's like, let me in the three stack after what...
After what pizza was doing.
He's like, you know what?
I'll go through that again.
But like, consensual.
But consensually agree to be part of it.
I remember, I think like, Sakura's stream...
Was in my recommended ones.
I remember Sakura.
Because...
He unfortunately dropped to Celestial at one point.
And then he was like, trio stacking with two other pros.
And it was one of the most beautiful crashouts I've ever watched live.
LOL
Why are you seeing all of this?
It was like...
It was like a car crash that you couldn't stop looking.
Because the other two were on like, alt accounts.
They were like, trying to save their friend, you know?
But they can't save him from himself.
LOL
Oh shit, I'm not paying attention anymore.
I'm not...
I'm not paying attention.
And then...
And I remember, like...
I remember this stream because it was just...
It was like, every game was like that last game that we watched.
That we were part of.
Like, every game was like that.
And it was like...
Because one of them was like, who used to be rank one.
And he was like, how is this happening?
He was like, how is this happening?
I used to be rank one.
And then...
Sekiro would like, type in the team chat, match chat, and be like...
All three of us used to be rank one.
And then his friends were like, why are you adding yourself into this?
You've never been rank one before.
You're like, stop saying you're rank one.
And I remember that stream because it was literally like...
Like, I just couldn't...
It was literally like a car crash.
I don't even know if you got out of Cel...
I mean, clearly you got out of Celestial.
But like, I don't even know...
How long that took.
I am not...
Okay, I need to focus up.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, pizza.
Don't worry, Mr. Raccoon.
I miss every shot.
It's fine, he didn't though.
He didn't miss.
Oh, I knew he...
Look at that.
Don't worry, I save you.
I save...
He did not try to use the name for his cover.
I tried to jump up to it.
Bro was locked on.
Oh shit, okay.
He bounced.
Bro actually bounced a little bit.
Oh no.
He's going through a little gangbang right there.
Wait, and he's alive?
No, he's not alive.
He is...
He's...
There were five people on that man.
Oh my god.
There was actually five people on top of him.
That was crazy.
Okay.
I mean, we all watched it live.
Together.
What does that say about us?
It was like a little show for all of us.
All 3k of us.
I thought he was...
Oh my god, I love how...
Um...
Canon-wise...
About Mr. Fantastic...
He's like an actual freak.
He has it.
What?
It's true!
Oh, that's...
No way!
I thought I was so far.
I can't believe it.
We have...
Can we touch it?
Yeah, we can.
Nice.
I'm going in.
Let's go!
Yeah.
Come on.
Nice, we did it.
Wait, that wasn't him.
That was...
Pizza!
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I swear.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He's gone.
Everything is fine.
I knew I could trust in my team.
The fear!
Look, after three slam dunks, I was worried he was gonna go LeBron on me again.
The pure terror.
Yeah, like, I don't know.
I think I have trust issues now.
Not gonna lie.
He definitely has slam.
I'm fucking backing up.
Oh no, not the cart.
Oh no.
Please.
Nice.
Our team is doing it.
It's fine.
Only now...
Well, sometimes, like...
Sometimes, I get to the phases where I was like...
I'm in an ELO where...
Goodbye.
I don't think you solved the problem.
Okay.
But you know, when you get into an ELO where you're like...
Alright.
My Magnetos.
Will save my life, right?
I was reloading.
But like...
Now I don't know.
Oh yeah, by the way.
You can reflect that as Vantas.
Oh, I timed that wrong.
I thought I timed that correctly.
Wait, that's not my Hella.
Whoops.
Alright.
I thought it was like...
Yippee!
My Hella's gonna protect me and I was gonna run straight to them.
Alright.
I was literally running to them.
Running straight at that enemy Hella.
Oh my god!
Bick!
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
Everything is fine.
What's he gonna do?
I missed my freeze.
He's gonna do something.
I can't believe I missed the freeze on the most fucking tankiest guy ever.
He's so wide.
Fuck, I lagged a little bit.
He's gonna do something now.
He's like one.
Not enough.
Alright.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Look at that.
We have so much time over them.
Like, nothing bad's gonna happen.
Where is he go- Okay.
I realized, like, I need to stop playing with Fate.
Woo!
Let's go!
I can kill him too.
Look at that.
Wait, there's a Hella right here.
Get him!
Oh no.
Oh, he has that.
He has that ult.
I can see it in his eyes.
He's going for it.
I'm fucking going backwards.
You can't get me if I'm 20 miles away from him.
I don't know why, but this game feels so- This match in particular feels incredibly slow.
I feel like we've been fighting for, like, 20-
There's nothing I can do.
I just- I just die.
I just die.
I look behind me.
And there was no other option.
Just dodge it.
Let me dodge a fucking- Oh!
What about the dinosaurs?
Did the dinosaurs fucking just dodge it?
Huh?
Were the dinosaurs able to just fucking dodge it?
What happened to the dinosaurs?
They could've.
Yeah, where did they- Why didn't they just fucking jump over the meteorite?
Huh?
Alright, let me see him.
Pizza's down to ruin someone's mental again.
Do you want to three stack?
Let's see how bruised Sakura's ego is if Pizza says no.
He's a masochist and likes being abused by you.
Oh, wait.
Ma- Masoch-
Sit.
What?
Okay.
Was it Sakura OW?
Invite over.
Okay.
No shot.
Alright.
Why'd you do him like that?
I like how we had an insta-queue too.
I don't know how this is gonna go.
The only person not as main is Sakura.
Me and Pizza are just vibing.
Alright.
Banning.
I mean...
I'll just do Wolverine.
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
Yeah, I'm not trolling, bro.
They got three fantastic players.
You gotta ban that, bro.
Oh my god.
Thanks for the 100 gifted, buddy.
Holy shit.
Well, not me, but...
Thanks for the 100 gifted!
Thank you!
Holy shit!
Wait, we banned MrFantastic?
Wait.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, thank you.
Thank you for the 100 gifted.
I don't think you...
It's looking crazy.
It's actually crazy.
But thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
Well, Pizza tried to ban Groot.
Did it go through?
Hey, what were the bans?
Groot wasn't even banned!
Alright.
How the fuck did that happen?
Oh my god.
I mean, I'm just a support.
I'm a support player.
I just play any support that's meta because I'm a meta slave.
I literally...
Meta, I learn.
I have no free will.
My main SR gains.
I don't believe it.
What do you mean?!
Oh shit, okay.
Inspired?!
Oh my god, I have not seen Pizza on Punisher.
Oh wait, no I have.
I know I have.
I saw that in the...
In the sort of...
The only time I've seen it is they lost.
But like, this will be different.
The only person on their main is Sakura.
So like, we're losing nothing here.
Nothing is lost, technically.
If you think about it.
Nothing is lost.
Alright.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Where's our mag?!
Oh!
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Everything...
Oh my god, okay.
Nothing is okay anymore.
Wait, why did we use Namor?
How the fuck are we using Namor out there?
We could have damage boosted it.
Namor, no!
We could have been best friends.
Maybe he'll swap.
No, he's not swapping.
He's just stupid.
Alright.
I'll be fine.
I believe in Pizza.
I believe in him.
Where's our Namor?
Where's our...
I hear...
I hear the Hela right above me.
Is she dead?
Oh, she is.
Oh!
No way!
I'm a hero!
Let's go!
I'm still a hero!
Something will hap... okay.
I guess I die?
Oh no, I'm alive.
Hey guys?
I don't think the fantastic ban was it.
I'm not sure yet.
I'm not sure yet, guys.
Guys!
Oh man!
Is that karma?
It's okay.
I believe in Pizza.
Pizza, you got this Pizza.
You got this.
You were ranked...
You were a top 10.
You got this.
You were top 10.
You're locking!
Jesus Christ.
I am so scared right now.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
I...
I can't!
Break my wrist.
Oh, I hear the Hela too.
I can't live!
It's so weird.
Why did they have all of the assaults?
Where are my...
Where are all of their ults?
Don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
I...
I literally dodged like three...
Three different things at once.
Three real ones for once.
Yeah, I dodged the Hela.
Then there was the Maggot.
And...
And then I got hit by Namor.
What more do they want from me?
What more do they want?
Guys, it's holdable.
Guys, it's so holdable.
We got this.
Wait, wasn't Yunaim the one that got flamed by my entire...
By the...
By the enemy team last game?
Guys, this is about a street cred.
From a...
From an Iron Fist Fantastic player.
An academy girl.
Oh my god.
What's going on right now?
I'm a little...
Concerned about what's going on everywhere.
I'm a...
I'm a little concerned.
Okay, I...
I'm very concerned.
I'm...
I'm very, very concerned.
Oh.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna live.
Guys.
I'm so scared.
Guys, I'm so scared.
I almost had my ult.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
We're gonna...
Guys.
Maybe...
That's not fantastic.
That was less fantastic.
Damn.
That was a little awkward there.
It's alright.
It's just...
It just wasn't it, guys.
We're figuring out the chemistry, guys.
We're just figuring out the chemistry.
It's okay.
The chemistry...
We'll get there.
Alright?
We're having the...
It's like...
It's like, you know...
It's like enemies to lovers.
Right now.
They're at the...
Pizza and Sakura are at the enemies phase.
But we'll slowly get there.
And then they'll be like BFFs.
It's our favorite trope.
Yeah, and then they'll be roommates.
I can see the vision.
Did all of us just forgot?
Oh, we don't.
I'm gonna banish.
Hi-ya!
Oh no, we have hella players.
Oh wait, this is practically the same team.
Oh, we got the same team.
We actually...
We actually got the same team.
Okay.
Then I don't know what to ban.
I guess I don't.
Fuck it.
This time it'll work, guys.
Maybe the enemy team will be easier now.
This is it.
No, it bugs out a lot.
It bugs out.
Sometimes it works and sometimes it doesn't.
Oh my god, thank you for the raid money!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Please let me play Loki.
Or I'll play Sue, actually.
I'll enable Pizza.
Oh, for those who don't know me, my name...
My name...
I forgot my own name.
My name is DokiBanon.
I usually stream on...
I used to stream on YouTube.
I almost said Twitch.
I'm deteriorating as a person.
I usually stream on YouTube, but now I'm here on Twitch for my Marvel Rivals quota.
Yeah, I'm DoeKitty.
You're right, I'm DoeKitty.
Today.
And then I'm going to be...
And then the moment the day is over, you're going to see me behind the farm.
Because they told me I'm going to get some special treats behind the farm.
And then I'm totally going to be okay.
No!
They said that I'm going to have the best day ever behind the farm.
I wonder what that'll be.
Alright, TP.
I'm so excited.
It's my first time at the farm.
Wow!
What the fuck?!
Where am I?!
Like, where did I go?!
What the fuck?!
Surprise!
I actually disappeared.
I was not expecting that.
That was crazy.
That was a wild ride.
I was like, what the fuck, where are they?
And then suddenly, there they are.
Jesus Christ, I'm sorry.
There's nothing I could do.
It was terminal.
Don't worry.
He'll be fine, right?
He was not fine, guys.
He was not fine.
Hey guys, remember when I said, don't worry, maybe it'll be better against this new team?
It doesn't look like it right now.
No,
you will not die!
What can I do?
I can't pull these guys.
It's a thing.
Wait, that's not fair.
He used a support ult.
That's cheating.
Don't worry, I got you.
I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking hero.
I got it.
Alright.
Guys,
I don't think I can play with another rocket one trick if I don't have a triple support.
I don't think I'm strong enough for this.
Guys, I don't think I'm strong enough.
I need another defensive ult.
What is that like?
What is that like to have two defensive ults?
Oh my god.
I did it!
He was on top of the stairs!
I was ready to push!
I was ready when the stairs went up.
I can't believe it!
Oh my god.
Wait, maybe Pizza is Mr. Fantastic.
I don't know how he does it though.
Look at you.
You go, buddy.
Look at you go.
Bro, he's him.
He's simply fantastic.
What's up?
Um...
Okay.
I have a feeling he has ult, guys.
Oh, nice.
Oh, unlucky.
It's fine.
I got a shield on him.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna beat you up.
Wait, no.
We just... We just gotta kill the thing.
Here's the thing.
Wait, how is he still alive?
Oh my god.
Please.
Please kill him.
Oh no.
They stalled it for so long.
I pushed him!
Yay!
I did it!
I finally know how to use my push.
See guys?
All I have to do is enable pizza.
That's all I have to do.
Wait.
Oh no.
Bro, you... Oh, things I wanna say.
Say it.
You sound worse than I do.
Who has a better voice?
Me or eating pizza?
Well, you are worse.
In every way.
This is... In what way?
Okay, same thing, bro.
Like, in what way am I worse than you?
Tell me, right now.
I can name one.
Uh, this game.
Oh, didn't pizza get top 10?
If I had 5 hours on any character you played, kid, I'd be so much better than you at it.
I swear to God.
Oh my goodness.
You give me 5 hours on your main, I'd be so much better than you at it.
I'm really, really sorry.
Damn!
Why?
Stop fighting!
Why can't we be friends?
Why can't...
Yeah, I think we're definitely still in the enemy's phase.
But they're working together!
It's just that he...
Oh my God, I got... I got so scared.
I don't... I could not tell if we were gonna live or not.
I can't tell.
I'm gonna stay invisible.
I can't.
He shot randomly and it somehow got me.
How did he know?
I was invisible!
You're right, it's a slow burn right now.
Woah.
Do you guys see the tension?
When they're like...
Name one thing you're better than me and then Pizza was like...
This game.
Woah!
I love slow burn!
Hahaha!
Don't worry.
You just don't know it.
You don't know it.
They're gonna be like roommates.
How
did the punch change trajectory?!
Oh wait!
Holy shit!
The punch changed trajectory!
That should be impossible!
No!
Oh my god!
I went... I like...
Dropped down to the other side cause I was like...
I couldn't...
Didn't get me.
I even like... I like...
Went a different direction.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Control... Control F kiss.
That's my cheat sheet.
For those who wanna know.
This is the best I can do right now.
There you go.
I got it just in time.
I pulled him back a little bit.
Oh no.
He almost got it.
Don't worry.
I believe.
Oh my god!
Piss!
Oh nice!
We got it!
Okay.
Oh nice!
He didn't know.
That's right.
They don't know.
They don't know I'm on the high ground.
Look at that.
They don't know.
Okay.
I see it.
Hey you too.
You too blue.
You too.
What?
They're not even close.
Bye bye!
They're five.
Oh I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh no.
Do I get the rez?
I do!
Oh no.
No.
No I'm so close.
Yes!
I got it.
I got it in time but I don't know where.
I don't know.
Goodbye.
That's the GG's right now.
Yep.
Goodbye.
Oh shit.
Hello.
Oh no!
No!
You brought me back here to suffer!
I'm trying!
No.
It's okay.
We just wanted to look at the portal a little closer.
I got rezzed back into the pit of hell.
I got rezzed back into the underworld.
Why would we be brought back?
I got a small taste of freedom.
And they're like, you know what?
This will change the game.
I wanna play Loki.
Not fair.
God bless.
Alright, this is it.
Dude, talk to me.
How much damage do you have right now?
Uh, more than you would need.
How much?
22 games.
Oh my god, dude.
Wait, you're the dude?
Nevermind, you own me.
Oh my god, look at that.
See, he's starting to accept it.
He's starting to accept.
Oh my god.
Hello.
We're gonna be best friends, you and I.
It's fine, we're so healthy.
It's fine.
I'm a hero.
Bro, ever.
I live.
Okay,
I deserved that.
I left Loki.
I was like, you'll be fine.
Guys, maybe I shouldn't have left the Loki, guys.
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm invisible.
If she dies, I'm sorry.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
And I'll always be a hero.
I got this.
What the fuck?
How did I...
Okay, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
He definitely has...
I know he has...
Oh my god, what?
It was on damage!
What?
I was like, wait a minute.
I'm not getting healed.
From the ult.
Wait a minute.
I was like, wait.
That's weird.
Wait, no.
He wants to...
That Loki wants to be a hero too.
But there can only be one hero.
I didn't know he was gonna do that.
The moment I saw the fucking Sylas, I fucking ran in there like that.
I don't know.
I don't know if we could have stacked it.
We could have stacked it, I think.
I think we could have stacked it, but...
Okay, I think it's time.
I think it's time.
Okay,
heal.
Oh, we're so dead.
Oh my god, there was no living that.
Guys, I did my best.
No.
Okay, I...
I think like...
We definitely should not have ran Rocket there in the beginning.
It's okay, the next game will be different.
The next game will be different, guys.
It's okay.
I believe.
I'm gonna avoid because I don't wanna...
I cannot have a Rocket player if we're not running triple support.
There's no reason to...
Oh!
Oh wait, Taco's done.
Taco's done.
He's like, it's over.
Taco, go away.
Wait, what?
Oh wait, yum yum yum yum yum.
GG's.
The problem left me with...
Okay, I'll do one more game.
And then I'll GG.
Yum yum yum yum yum.
I'll do one last game.
I need to eat a fish every time.
Every time.
I need to eat a fish.
Alright, this time.
Fish equals win?
No, I'll eat it for a little bit and then...
I think...
That was crazy though.
Win.
Let's secure it.
Made like a sly comment.
To other support.
And he's just like, never mind.
Nothing.
I think Taco went to bed.
Oh sorry, Pizza.
Pizza went to bed.
I'm pretty sure.
Abandoned her like...
What is it?
Twice?
I think?
One was on purpose because I thought it was funny.
But also she was on rocket.
Rocket is like so easy to not kill.
If I sacrifice my life for a rocket, I die.
Because like...
It's harder for the rocket to pocket the other support versus...
Versus like...
Rocket pocketing the other support.
I have so many instances where...
The rocket just has to like...
Have really good movement.
Yeah, if I sacrifice...
I did it!
I tried to sacrifice my life and I died.
And then I was like...
I learned my lesson.
Alright.
Let's see.
I don't know.
I don't think I've ever had to save a rocket before.
I'm like trying to...
Let's see.
I'm trying to think of when I have to save a rocket.
Alright.
No matter what happens...
This is LG.
Yeah, if a rocket needs saving, that's a problem.
Yay!
I can play Loki!
But no, this is my LG for the day.
No matter what.
I was gonna call that one LG.
Yay!
I get to play Loki!
I don't know.
I just don't like it when people force rocket.
Especially in this ELO.
If it was higher ELO, I understand.
But like...
In this ELO...
I don't like it because like...
People don't understand how to actually properly play him.
To utilize him where he's actually good now.
As double support.
If you utilize him as a triple support, I'm fine.
I don't give a fuck.
But the enemy team had two defensive ults.
There's a way to high skill...
Yeah.
There's a...
There's a way to high skill...
High skill rocket.
But I've only...
The only good rocket players I know are not rocket mains.
They're support players.
Okay, I was gonna say...
Did we break the glass?
I was gonna say...
That would be so awkward if we broke the glass there.
Oh.
There.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
My...
Oh, no!
My Loki clone didn't put forward!
I was trying to put my Loki clone up and it didn't register!
No!
My Loki clone didn't register!
Yeah, just having one defensive ult is really rough.
It'd be fun if we had a...
Bucky and Punisher, but I don't think...
It's okay.
He's the only one that's on his main.
And I'm okay.
What the fuck?
Who was that?
I wasn't paying attention.
That was... Whoa, hey!
Yay!
Oh, not yet!
Not yet!
Yay!
Not yet.
I went through, like, the five stages.
I went through, like, so many motions there.
I went through so many motions.
Oh, man.
I just didn't know how to feel.
Okay.
Don't worry, I got you!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's good.
That's okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, I got fucking flew up.
I got flew up!
I'm sorry!
I was flew up into the air!
Is that a new account?
I'm getting question marks by AvaFPS because she hit the roller slow walk on me.
It's like fucking crip walk that I missed.
Oh, my... Whoa!
Whoa, unlucky.
This pal is good.
I can't ego her.
I need to stop egoing her.
Oh, my God.
You can tell like...
Knight is... I'm getting tired.
You can tell... I'm definitely getting tired now.
That's why I was letting this potentially pass to be last game.
Oh, my God.
What am I getting hit by?
Yeah, my battery is flashing red.
What?
That was 200 things.
Wait.
I'm a hero.
Did you see that?
They were all red and then they were not.
They were all red and then suddenly...
Oh, my God.
I'm actually a hero.
Okay, she dodged it.
No.
Oh, my God.
I can't peek her.
No.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That was scary.
That was actually scary.
Oh, my God.
This is scary.
What?
How am I getting hit by that?
I don't know.
I don't know how I'm getting hit.
I literally don't even see the mag.
When it happens.
Or maybe I'm tired.
I don't even see the mag.
Alright.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
That was my bad.
I did not see him.
That's okay.
You're on your main.
I'm not.
I'm chilling.
Oh, okay.
Don't keep playing with me.
I'm just surprised you're running Moon Knight.
I'm trying to keep you up right now.
Alright.
Doing good.
Reload.
Fuck.
Jesus Christ.
I have to reload.
Jesus.
Please.
Oh, my God.
You think they're okay?
I don't think they're okay.
I don't know if they're okay.
Guys, I don't think they're okay, guys.
I have my ult soon, though.
Yippee!
Nah, yippee.
Oh, absolutely.
I'm not feeling yippees anymore.
It's okay.
Yippee?
Time?
Is it yippee time?
Oh, my God.
Please.
Oh, please.
I have no DPS.
Alright.
Where is it?
Oh, here you go.
There you go.
I saved you.
You're welcome.
I'm still trying to save you right now.
Please, please.
I'm trying to save you.
They're still stalling.
Oh, my God.
I hate you.
Are they still...
Please.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my goodness.
Bro, I can't kill anything.
Nobody killed the thing.
It's crazy.
It's actually crazy.
We could shoot a rocket.
Holy shit, bro.
Eating pizza just owns me.
I give up, bro.
Well, you can't expect to win at all.
I think it's over for that man.
I think it's over.
That's fucking hilarious.
He's finally admitted it this time.
Alright.
Time to head to the bar.
You're right.
It's time.
It's time to head to the bar.
I told you, guys.
I told you.
I knew what I was...
I knew what I was gonna get into the moment I get out of solo queue.
I knew exactly what was gonna happen.
I was like...
I was like, okay, the moment I get out of solo queue, it's gonna be a wild ride.
I was not there to climb.
I...
I was...
I was not...
I was not there to climb anymore.
The moment I went there.
But I had a great solo queue adventure, though.
An incredible solo queue adventure.
Yeah, we traded wins for content.
Exactly, guys.
Exactly.
We got lots of wins from that.
We got lots of wins and then we got content.
We got the best of both worlds, chat.
Did we climb today?
We went up.
We were climbing.
And then I...
I started stacking.
But we had fun.
We had fun.
This account is not about...
This account is not about trying to get as high as we can.
It's about...
It's about having fun.
One final...
Do I do one?
And I kidnapped two people.
I kidnapped two people.
Okay.
If I do one more game, we're down a game.
I'd rather we start...
We go positive here.
I'd rather...
Alright, you see...
I'm on an alt account.
So I'm having fun.
Wait, how...
What's this E though?
Let's check it live on stream.
Little does he know.
I know the trick.
I'm not just a regular player.
I play.
Oh.
Ouch.
Alright, but like...
You can tell when I started stacking.
So like...
Right here.
Solo, solo, solo, solo, solo, solo, solo.
And then I joined the stack.
I joined.
Right here.
But...
It was like...
We don't talk about what happened here.
I lost.
I think I was like 1-4 or something.
Or like 4-1.
But yes.
We're gonna end on a high note everybody.
I had fun.
I made new friends.
Guys, see?
I'm still making new friends and my rivals.
I'm having fun.
That's all that matters.
Yay.
Sky, thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
But thank you everybody for watching.
I really appreciate it guys.
For those who are new here.
My name is Doki Bird.
I almost forgot my name.
Because I was like, no I'm Doki.
No I'm Doki Bird.
Anyway.
This is a short stream.
Because I have a stream at 12.30 on YouTube.
For those who don't know me.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check me out there.
I usually tweet out whenever I stream on Twitch on Twitter.
So follow me on there if you want to know when I stream on Twitch.
What else?
If you want to support me via other means.
I do have merch being sold at the moment.
I think I have two more days left.
On my official plushies.
So please.
Wait.
Do I have pictures of it?
Oh my god.
Where's the pictures for it?
Give me a sec guys.
Please stay so I can show one last time.
But the exclamation point merch.
Or plush.
I do have some of my official plushies being sold right now.
There is two days left.
So please check it out.
Make sure to buy it.
Because it will be gone forever.
It will be gone forever.
If you don't get them in the last two days.
I guess that's everything.
As always.
Thank you so much for all the Twitch subs.
For all the follows.
For all the bitties.
I really appreciate it.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.